を
私は三年の間
この森の中で
zen by が切れた人形のように
ただたが座っていることしか出来ない時がありました
その時
聞こえてきたのは
パワーを流れる水ノート
気にをゆらす風
豆腐かが聞こえる鳥の声
そして
見上げると
白い雲が流れていました
18年前の春
私は突然の女前に襲われ
そのまま病と暮らす日々が始まりました
そしてその日々の中で出会ったのが森でした
私の症状は
ひどい倦怠感とめまい頭痛
睡眠障害と合わせて
精神的にとても苦しかったのが
感情の起伏が激しく気持ちが抑えられないときにはクローゼットを倒してしまったり
ひどく落ち込むともう生きていることが困難だと思い
自分の命を絶とうとしたことが何回もありました
その時私に見えていた景色は
家の窓から見える庭にある木々と
その間に広がる青い空
病院という
箱のような空間
そして
ベッドの上から見える
四角く切り取られたような窓の外の景色でした
私の日常は
朝家族を見送ることもできず
誰もいなくなった後に
重くなった体をようやく引きずるように起き上がり
夕方[ __ ]なを保育園に迎えに来
夕飯を作るのがやっとこ
という日々でした
はそんな私と子供を
夫である好さんは
自然の中に連れて行ってくれました
ちょっと薄暗い森を歩き森を抜けると目の前に輝く3というのが広がり
きれいな川が流れ
青い空が広がっていました
そんな中で3人は魚釣りをしたり
むしろをとったり
そんな風にして時間を過ごしていました
私はというと
そんな家族を見ながら
ただただ座っているか
時には深い眠りに陥りました
その時
上の子は8歳
下の子は5歳でした
そのような毎日を
3年ほど食っているある日
私の中に
守りの前で今目の前で繰り広げられている森の景色を書きたい
という気持ちが湧き上がってきました
その気持ちを好さんに伝えると36色のパステルというが剤をプレゼントしてくれまし
た
始め私は何を描いていいのかよくわからず
色だけ塗っていましたが
だんだん東森で出会った生き物を描けるようになっていきました
その作品を見ると家族はお母さん
よく描けたねと言ってくれました
私は
その言葉が嬉しくて
1日1枚1日1枚と思って体調の時良い時に描き続けました
そうしているうちに私の体に変化が起きてきたのです
投薬の量が減りいい
主治医から
もうツインしなくていいよと言われました
倒れてから4年が経過していました
大変嬉しかったのを覚えています
そして
自分に何が起きたんだろうと考えるようになりました
そこで建てた過程が
森で出会ったものを表現し
それを受け止めてくれる人がいれば人の命はいきいき済むのではないか
ということです
私の場合は
家族が受け止めてくれました
けれど受け止めては加速でなくてもいいんじゃないか
そう考え
心理学の分野を探し
芸術療法というものに出会い
それを学び始めました
けれど私にとって芸術療法だけでは足りなかったのです
私にとって大切なのは森で出会ったということでした
っと
森の中で繰り広げられている命後つながりをもっと知りたい
人と森との命後長いを知りたい
そう思って私は信州大学の森林生態学の研究室に研究生として入り
学ぶことになりました
治癒してから6面が立っていました
森林生態が高慢ノブにあたりであった森が
長野県木島平村カヤノ平にあるブナ人です
私はこのブナ林の中で
まさに命の営みを目の当たりにすることができました
こちらは
ブナの朽木に付いた
赤ゲラーという木つつ木が開けた穴です
この穴の下へ行くと
アカゲラのヒナの声が聞こえてきました
こちらは同じこの機に付いたクマの爪痕です
このように
姿は見えなくても
生き物の息吹を感じると私の心は
work ワークしてきました
このブナ林の中では
小さなブナの食べが次の年
芽吹
成長し
若々しい緑のブナの森を作ります
しかしすべてがそのまま成長できるわけではなく
途中で淘汰され朽ちていくものもあります
また400祭後100歳という大所になるものもあります
この大樹になったものもいつかは死を迎え
菌類に分解され
土に還り
また新しい命をはっくものです
この当たり前に見える延々と続く命の循環は実はこの森で暮らすさまざまな生き物たち
が日々自分の命を守り自分の遺伝子をつないでいこうとする
見方によっては利己的にさえ見える
その命のつながりが複雑につながりあって出来上がっている大きな循環なんです
私は森林生態学を学ぶことにより
この循環を科学的な目を持って見ることができるようになりました
もう一つこの部なじんで私の出会った大きなものがあります
俺が山の神の木です
山の神の聞いてあった時私は
先人と森との命のつながりを見たと思いました
生態学という科学と
科学では到底証明することは困難と思われる
山の神というものと二つが私の中で一つになった時
それまでと違った
新たな創造の世界が広がりました
18年前私は
限られた空間の中でしか暮らせませんでした
しかし今
森という疲労異空間へ自らの意思で趣
今そこを仕事場としています
もし森へ行ってみたい
と思われた方はどうぞ森の生き物の生活を少しでも知っている人と行ってみてください
そこに繰り広げられる命のつながりが見えてくると思います
そして今森へ行くことがちょっと難しいという方は
窓の外に目を向けてみてください
そこにも必ず命の営みがあります
私はこれからも
森の中で仕事を c
森が案内をし
そして
作品を作り
これまで出会ってきたたくさんの生き物たちが教えてくれたこと
そしてこの大きな森が伝えてくれたことを皆さんに伝えていきたいとおもいます
そこにあるメッセージは只一つなんです
それは
あなたの命が
そこにあることが
一番大切である
ということです
皆さんも自分自身に
言ってみませんか
そして一番大切な人にも
ています
ん